欢迎各位说明今天这期摆车圈说我是三刀。
今天这期节目跟大家聊一聊前段时间的一个新闻。
特斯拉帽豆外现在是全球最畅销的乘用车型，
不加任何的定语。
也就是说不分是轿车也不分SUV，
不分插混也不分什么燃油、纯电，
就所有的车型地球上它是目前卖的最好的。
一开始我对这个新闻还有一点点迟怀疑的态度。
我就上网搜了一下，
然后我发现其实去年的12月31号，
马斯克在他的X上就已经发布了这样的一个事情，
相当于他个人就官宣了嘛。
说我们已经2023、2425、23年我们已经是全球最畅销的乘用车了。
只不过因为大家这个没有，
大部分人是没有这个能力去看国外的网站的，是吧。
但是我知道我们网友也会有一些人，
对吧，经常回去对吧，去看看喵一喵国外的一些新闻。
有的人是刷到了，有些人是不知道的，
但是今年是相当于特斯拉的这个官方，
就中国的官方网站是官宣了，连续三年都是全球第一。
那么这个全球第一是什么概念的？
我估计很多人跟我想法一样，
就是这个车卖的再好，
它也是个二三十万的车，
那国外可能卖的比国内还要再贵一点。
那么这个车它再怎么讲也是二三十万，
全球有那么多人花二三十万去买一个电动车吗？
它难道说卖的比卡罗拉还要好吗？
结果一查，它还真的卖的就比卡罗拉要好。
那我当时在思考这个问题，
它怎么会卖的比卡罗拉还好呢？
后来我想了一下，极重可能性。
第一个，其实现在大环境大家都知道，
并没有那么好，
也并不是说真的有那么多的人去花二三十万去买个电车，
特别是其他国家，
因为全球电车基本上70%的市场份额都在中国，
但是你要思考一个问题，
它其实统计的是新车的销量，
那其实我们知道在海外很多的地方，
你不管是在欧洲还是在美国，
甚至包括在像什么澳大利亚，
像这些日本这些地方，
很多人是不买新车的，
他们是买二手车的，
而且很多的一些发达国家，
它的二手车的销量是比新车销量更大，
但是这个统计的只是新车的销量，
而新车的销量老外也是人，
老外也不可能说你今年开个三四十万的车，
明年换成一个十几万的车，
就是曾经开过卡罗拉的这些人，
他们陆陆续续在换车也想换更好一点的，
对不对，
所以如果是统计新车的销量的话，
那其实买猫的外的，
绝大部分都是支换，
绝大部分都是买新，
对不对，老外到目前为止应该还不至于说，
去二车市场去讨一辆二手的，
这种什么准新的，
或者什么三连十万公斤的特色蓝猫的外，
但是这种情况应该再过个几年，
陆陆续续就是海外的这种，
比方说二手电车，
它的保有量越来越大，
然后老百姓也开始对于二手电车，
有了更多的了解，
包括甚至第三方的检测，
搭得非常的清楚，
就是什么样的电车适合买，
什么样不适合买，
它的量级肯定也是会，
从新车的销量转换成二手的销量，
就是普遍来讲对于国外的这些，
就是比较成熟的汽车市场，
就是大家对于车的这种认知，
那更多的还是二手更划算，
能买二手车，
它就是工具嘛，
能买二手就当二手，
开开就行了，
对不对，
就像你说你去给孩子去买个自行车，
对吧,
当然自行车这个比喻可能太便宜了，
就像有些人可能去买个电动自行车，
像我们家有一辆电动自行车，
我当时搬家的时候，
我其实都准备送给邻居了，
我媳妇说还能再骑一起，
结果就跟着我们搬家的货车就一起搬过去了，
搬过去之后有些时候就是这样，
这个东西你不能说你不想要了，
它感觉是有邻性的，
你一说你不想要了，
它马上就坏，
结果开过去没多久那个电瓶就不太行了，
那我们肯定是不可能给这么旧的一个电动车换电瓶，
后来把它挂在咸鱼上卖，
结果那么破个电动车，
我当时说这台车子能卖个200块钱就不错了，
我媳妇上网一搜说人家像同样比它还要再旧，
还要再破的，
还能卖个500，
它挂了个600多块钱卖，
结果还真的就差不多接近600块钱把它给卖掉了，
我当时本次不得其解，
我说这么破的一个电动车，
你就算说句不好听，
你送我骑，
我都不一定肯骑，
买它的是个大学生，
那个大学生我们跟他说的也很清楚了，
比方说转向灯左边的不太亮了，
你可以要修一下，
然后这个电瓶的续航有限，
我估计也就只能开到10来公里，
他说没事没事，
我就在学校周边转一转，
而且我充电非常方便，
楼底下就能充，
他就把它卖回去了，
那对他来讲可能就这500多块钱，
600块钱,
他就完全刚需，
长续航对他来讲没有意义，
他天天就可以充电嘛，
对不对，
但是对于我们来讲的话，
因为我媳妇经常接送孩子，
你天天充电不方便，
就这个车子就把它给卖掉了，
所以对于不同国家，
不同人对于车辆的理解和定位不一样，
他对于买新车跟买二手车，
就跟我们就完全想法是不一致的，
所以他这个所谓的就是全球第一，
他确实是全球第一，
而且是超了卡罗拉了，
而且他全球到今天为止，
国内的新闻其实重点想讲的不是全球第一，
而是model y全球累计的销量已经突破400万辆了，
就是秀一下，
秀一下他的400万辆，
那秀这个400万辆是什么概念呢，
就是第一个是刷刷存在感嘛，
对吧,
特斯拉这两年说实话，
存在感也比以前弱了很多，
那么第二一点呢，
就是要告诉大家，
他是一个成熟车型，
非常成熟的车型，
全球化的车型，
并且全世界地球上400万个家庭都在开这个车，
那么你作为400万当中的其中一员，
你怕什么呢，
对吧,
你真出了什么问题，
我给你兜底嘛，
而且400万辆卖出去之后，
你不管是整车价格也好，
还是零部件的价格也好，
今后的收获保养也好，
你包括特斯拉的整体的这种运营状况，
全球销量第一，
对吧,
然后同时400万辆的保底，
那你说有一天，
人家给你讲说电动车企就剩最后两家了，
你老子里面第一反应，
就这两家是哪个，
其中肯定有一家是特斯拉，
你包括燃油车企，
你说全世界都死光了，
就剩两家了，
你老子里面第一反应两家是哪个，
那基本上我觉得80%以上的人，
应该一个封田一个大中吧，
对吧,
就是死绝了之后，
就还剩两家，
那肯定就是一个封田一个大中，
我绝对是想不出来第三家了，
能比这两家还要再强一些的，
是不是，
所以特斯拉他宣布说，
Model Y是2023到2025年,。
连续三年全球最常行车型，
这个事情肯定是没有错的，
而且累计销量已经超过400万辆，
这肯定也是没有问题的，
这400万辆是全球销量，
不是中国销量，
但是中国肯定是至少占到四成以上，
那就中国至少供兴了100多万辆，
接近200万辆的Model Y，
那么其实我觉得这个400多万辆，
200万辆也不算多，
为什么呢，
因为我当时看了一下，
其实按照往年，
就是这个Model Y在国内的销量，
就已经非常非常强悍了，
你看Model Y在2023年，
是全球卖了122.3万辆，
当时是第一次登顶，
2024年有点下滑，
因为整体的市场大环境大家知道的，
其实经济环境整体都不太好，
全球都不太好，
那么它就卖到了118.5万辆，
也超了100万，
仍然是冠军，
到了2025年，
然后这个市场竞争开始加剧了，
很多的一些，
包括我们国产新能源开始发力了，
那么Model Y的销量是107万辆，
就是将将过了100万辆，
但是仍然还是全球冠军，
我说的这个数据是全球的销量，
然后你如果把它算成中国的销量的话，
应该要打个大概四折到五折的样子，
所以我们就说嘛，
就是在中国的话，
基本上也是供奖了100多万辆，
接近200万辆嘛，
对不对，
所以说，
它一年卖100多万辆，
超越了蜂田卡罗拉，
包括超越了蜂田的Raw 4，
这两个都是属于全球的这种冠军车型，
家喻户晓的，
你到任何一个国家去玩，
你在路上，
你多多少少是能看到的，
而且你像东南亚这些国家，
你基本上不叫多多少少，
你抬眼闭眼一看，
全是蜂田，
但是现在电车超越游车，
其实我觉得这是一个历史性的转折点，
不仅仅是特斯拉超越了蜂田，
或者是Model Y超越了卡罗拉，
而是电动车史上第一次夺得了全球销量的冠军，
而且它一夺得之后，
它就不下来了，
它就连续三年，
甚至包括今年2026年，
我看这个区市大概率可能也是，
因为今年有个五年免息，
中国市场肯定销量特别强劲嘛，
对吧,
可能连续四年，
都是全球销量冠军，
燃油车有没有翻身的可能性呢？
在现在目前大的政策下，
大的环境下，
有没有可能大家突然有一天反应过来说，
诶,
我觉得电动车也没什么好的，
我不想开特斯拉了，
我就想去新车，
我就去买一辆卡罗拉，
有没有这种可能性？
那我觉得历史这一页应该已经翻篇了吧，
如果是有国外的兄弟们，
你们跟我聊一聊，
你身边有没有的人，
开着开着电车突然有一天反悔了，
说我要回回头来再开游车，
游车我就认蜂田，
我就认大中，
怎么说呢？
其实整体来讲的话，
特斯拉包的外这个产品在我的理解当中，
它不算很优秀，
或者说这个产品本质上来讲，
也没有让人特别惊艳的一种感觉，
但是你会发现，
有些东西是这样子的，
就是它没有让你惊艳，
但是它让你能下决心，
这个很有意思，
就它没让你心动，
但是它能让你行动，
你比如说，
我前两天不是换了一个苹果手机吗？
我当时就百思不得其解，
我也不知道为什么，
我就看着看着看着，
我就突然想着想着，
我要把我的手机给换掉，
其实我也知道，
这个iPhone 13 Pro,。
我也能再称一层，
再用一用，
我一直没有去摸iPhone 17 Pro，
我到了店里面，
我那么一摸，
然后拍几张照片，
我一对比，
我的天，
那个像素那个清晰程度，
对不对，
那个手感，
我想了想，
我说省着钱有啥意义呢？
对不对，
你说那么拼有什么意义呢？
前段时间，
张雪峰老师也是，
对吧，不幸离世了，
我当时我一想，
钱不花，
留着干什么呢？
对吧,
未来和意外也不知道哪天先来，
赶紧就把它花了吧，
就刷一卡一刷，
就直接给它提回来了，
提完之后，
我再想，
我说过两天不行，
电脑好像也不太行了，
我要再换个电脑，
房子看也小了，
所以叫房子，
不至于，
不至于啊，
我只是想讲的就是，
特斯拉其实本质上来讲，
他就是，
可能一眼没让你心动，
但是他一定能让你行动，
那这个行动的背后，
他其实是一整套的逻辑，
什么叫做一整套的逻辑呢？
就是他的整体的产品的语言，
产品的定位，
他给你的感觉，
就是让你很轻松的，
能去下订单，
他不像有些产品，
我试的时候很兴奋，
看的时候很兴奋，
啊这个销售给你讲的时候，
各种功能都很兴奋，
可是正当你要买的时候，
你会发现，
他这个定价就有套路，
他就有一种逼着你去买顶配，
然后,
当你去看他的选装的时候，
你会发现，
他好东西全在选装里面，
然后你不选呢，
你觉得这刚才销售给你介绍的那些东西，
应该诗得挺过瘾的，
但是你选了吧，
你又觉得说，
这个车我本来是冲着他，
二十二三万来看的，
现在这个选一下，
那个选一下，
最后这个车变成三二多万了，
虽然说三十万，
我也不是掏不起这个钱，
但是我感觉我是被你套路，
我是被你这个，
一个坑一个坑的，
这个这个这个给买进去了，
这就很不舒服，
但特斯拉不是这样的，
特斯拉的价格就是，
非常透明，
一口价，
他甚至于难的给你讲，
他也不想给你解释那么多，
就这个价格，
你去看就是标绪的，
长绪的是两轮区的，
后轮区的还是说这个四区的，
你想清楚就行了，
你别搞那么复杂，
然后车子的车型点开来，
页面也非常简单，
对不对，
他所有的选装我曾经讲过，
特斯拉的选装，
他是不会歧视人的，
什么叫都不会歧视人，
你比方说有些车，
你不选，
你开出去，
那是那种颜色啊，
包括那个什么轮骨大小啊，
造型啊，
车没拉开，
对吧,
有没有NOMI啊，
当然这个我不去点名啊，
然后你包括像保时捷，
对吧,
保时捷是最恶心的，
保时捷甚至于轮骨上的那个标，
你不去加钱，
那个标都是灰色的，
我的妈呀，
你这什么意思呢，
就等于我花钱还要把标点亮，
你这个保时捷的标本来不就应该是彩色的吗，
真是恶心啊，
我的天哪，
不就是你不加钱，
标都是灰的，
所以你看，
有的时候我在路上看到那个保时捷的帕拉米尔，
帕米尔，
我看到那个标是灰色的，
我当时就在想，
我说这个老板都花了一百多万了，
不好意思啊，
约了一下，
我说这个老板都花了一百多万了，
他为什么就差那么万百块钱，
不去把这个标升级成彩色的，
我说句不好听的，
你哪怕，
你不花这万百块钱，
你把它买回来，
你上拼多多，
你上淘宝，
你去买个彩标，
你给它换上啊，
对不对，
又不是买不到，
这种什么二手的，
或者是，
这种什么什么，
第三方的这个甲冒伟烈的，
这个小轮骨标有什么无所谓的，
你给它装上去，
你怎么这，
反正是我，
我肯定是不可能开一个灰色的，
保尔爷的车标的轮骨，
在外面去晃的，
太丢人了，
是不是，
你哪怕你说帕拉米尔，
你不去选装那个后排鱼乐，
就是中央扶手后排鱼乐，
你是个大坑，
你不选那边就是个坑，
就是个奥曹，
你如果选，
那中间就是个仪表，
就是后排，
后排的中间扶手这个位置，
你这个打发不选，
你说你能忍我能接受，
但是你说这个标不选，
我真的是，
想不明白，
但是特斯拉在这一方面，
他没有做任何的区分，
你不管是车外还是车内，
不过他本身也没什么东西可以区分了，
那本身就是个毛皮房，
就是毛皮房，
就是毛皮房的样子，
所以高配地配，
大家都看就是看不出来，
对不对，
那么这样一来的话，
那很多人买车，
他就不会，
从心里面，
就是到了最后一步，
临门一脚的时候，
他不会说，
有一种，
怎么讲呢，
有一种就是叫尊严被践踏，
或者说就是，
心里面的那一点点，
虚的部分，
其实很多人买车是虚的，
真的,
你别听他讲说，
我要买奔驰，
我要买个什么，
二三十万，
小米苏七，
我要买问贱，
我要买理想，
其实我可以这么讲，
绝大多数人，
或者绝大多数家庭里面的现金流，
是非常差的，
你不能说差到离谱吧，
就是你以他的收入来讲的话，
他的现金存款，
其实并没有那么多，
因为大家都知道，
各家都是有很多花钱的地方，
老人如果身体好还好，
老人身体不好，
那你要交比先给医院，
对不对，
然后每一年，
你正常的话，
家里面成年人买保险，
孩子买保险，
小孩如果上了学之后，
小孩上了，
有的小学就开始补课，
对吧，初中也补，
高中也补，
那全都是钱，
如果是婴儿的话，
那还要买了一份，
就各种买小孩的衣服，
手推车，
然后每一年的旅行，
人家补一时一出去玩，
你不玩吗，
所以处处要花的是什么，
是现金，
我相信这些消费，
你不可能去贷款的吧，
难道说你还贷款消费，
不可能，
你都是现金，
所以你的现金的收入，
减去你现金的支出，
你最终就是账上，
你食下来的就是存款，
我相信，
绝大多数的人，
现金里面没有那么多，
不可能是那种动辄，
拿个二三十万，
就能把车买回来的那种人，
眼睛都不看，
眼睛都不必的，
但是绝大多数人，
他能接受贷款，
因为他对于，
很多人就是这样，
人对于自己的能力是无比自信的，
但是有的时候，
你的自信我不知道来源于哪里，
你是觉得老板对你好，
还是说，
你这个能力换任何工作，
都有人要，
其实在我看来有些东西，
风险是自己给自己造成的，
就是你没有认清环境，
没有认清事实，
我这个讲六年远，
我们还是回来讲，
所以,
特斯拉今年这个五年免息，
真的是非常有杀伤力，
就是Model Y这个五年免息，
我妈后面要讲，
那我们再讲一点，
就是这个产品，
它其实，
它销量第一，
你说它有什么特点，
它没什么特点，
而且这个车型，
虽然说连续三连都是全球第一，
然后在国内卖得也很好，
国外卖得也很好，
但你会发现，
七年了，
真的,
将近七年了，
这个时候外观内视几乎没怎么变，
几乎没怎么变，
那么七年前的设计，
到今天还能这么受欢迎，
我觉得唯一能解释的通的就是，
要么产品它是有设计的前瞻性，
对吧,
要么就是，
这个产品通过OTA，
它确实在软件层面上，
它是有很强的升级能力，
动不动可能动力还能给你升一下，
对不对，
然后这个车机导航以前不好用，
现在变得好用一点，
语音以前不好用，
现在语音稍微好用一点，
FSD不能落地，
这个不是特斯拉的问题，
这是国内的这个政策的问题，
安全性的问题，
对吧,
现在无人机也是，
基本上，
我不知道你们城市能不能进行，
能不能飞啊，
绝大多数城市都不能飞，
你像我马上我要从，
我要从广州一路自驾，
要去开到成都，
我从广州自驾去成都，
中间要路过贵州休息一个晚上，
我说,
我跟摄影师讲，
我说你把无人机带着，
摄影师跟我说，
这个我带了有什么用呢，
反正据我了解，
全国90%的城市都不能飞，
你飞起来之后，
你片子就是上线了，
马后面，
这个平台要问你，
你这一段，
这个无人机拍摄的画面，
有没有报备，
你拿不出报备，
你的片子就下架，
那你不如就不飞了，
哎,
我说那照理这么讲，
那大疆不就倒闭了吗，
那大疆的无人机卖的还有什么意义呢，
这点我不是很清楚啊，
大家能不能告诉我，
就大疆现在还能卖得动吗，
这个无人机，
所以我想讲的就是，
国内这个政策导致FSD不能落地，
那么FSD具体好还是不好，
它就成了一个迷，
大家都知道有一些，
比方说在美国的这个，
也不叫彻平人嘛，
就是汽车爱好者，
他们也会去拍，
对吧,
他们会拍的时候，
你看有的人就在那边狂吹，
FSD怎么怎么好，
FSD我觉得我完全能理解，
我也看过一些，
这种老外的这种，
怎么讲叫野生车屏，
我觉得他们在试FSD的时候，
给的评价都普遍就是，
很像一个老司机，
很聪明，
而且在，
就像美国这种，
就是它已经完全覆盖，
而且它的这个路线啊，
已经非常成熟的情况下，
基本上是能做到，
接近于自动驾驶，
我们讲的是在海外啊，
在国外，
但是呢，
他们也不敢讲是完全自动驾驶，
其实在国内呢，
它这个跟你的自动驾驶能力，
或者说辅助驾驶的能力强不强，
没有半毛钱的关系，
就是因为它本身，
你现在所有的都是走这个纯视觉路线，
然后,
其实我觉得服务器都在中国，
也没有什么问题，
但是因为它毕竟是个国外的企业，
它这个国外的就是全独自的一个企业，
你在国内，
现在特斯拉已经基本上能实现，
几乎是95%以上的这个国产零部件了嘛，
95%以上的零部件相当于就是你，
带动了整个国内的企业的发展，
就电动车的这个上下游的配套发展，
然后挣的钱具体留多少在国内，
我不知道，
以前跟上海是签这个对赌协议的嘛，
那么现在目前来讲，
一年大多少的税带动了多少就业，
咱们不是特别清楚，
但是我觉得，
应该是一个相当不错的数字，
因为这个企业就不要说在上海了，
当时我记得特斯拉想要去扩建的时候，
那全中国多少地方去抢啊我的天，
我继续说江苏这边也在抢啊，
也是想让它过来，
它就不行啊，
它就过不来，
最后不知还是在上海，
又继续扩建了嘛，
对不对，
你讲到这一点，
我真的又想再吐槽一下，
当年未来想要落地总部和工厂，
就是想落在南京，
南京和郑江巨龙这个位置，
结果据说小道消息，
坏就坏在拜腾嘛，
就是拜腾当年倒闭的那一年，
未来前后角就想去落在南京，
已经谈到差不多了，
结果就因为这件事情拜腾倒了以后，
就牵手到很多的一些，
就不能说的一些相关部门嘛，
那么就导致，
对吧他们就不敢说再把一个电动车企引入到南京来，
结果被河肥解了个虎，
啊上期节目我们再聊，
这个为什么齐瑞能够去考虑做可供和剧变，
啊上期节目很多人吐槽说这不就是瞎扯弹嘛，
什么可供和剧变啊，
其实我觉得这扯和不扯这件事情啊，
要看你把这个时间周期拉多长，
对不对，
那你当年怀特兄弟说人类能飞上南天，
那旁边也有人讲，
也有人讲说这是疯子啊，
这两个人就是神经病啊，
但是结果现在呢，
人类就是在天上熬响啊，
我今天不就是从南京一路从天上飞到北京来的嘛，
那比高铁还快，
是不是，
所以你让，
就是你让他在理论可行性的情况下去寻求，
技术性的突破，
而且他的这个整个的框架体系又不是不可能，
只不过没有找到，
就是目前人类没有找到合适的材料，
就像我讲的就一个大锅里面放两滴水，
把它挤压然后产生能量，
要烧到一亿度，
那这个东西你没有东西能沉得住啊，
那怎么办呢，
这材料学物理学各方面，
你要去突破啊，
人类不就是不停的突破嘛对吧，
那有人讲突破，
我突破到最后怎么办的，
一颗原子弹对吧，
一颗核桃弹就结束了，
哎,
这个东西不要那么悲观嘛对吧，
虽然说最终地球都是要毁灭的，
人类早晚也是要毁灭的，
但是,
人在这世上这短短的几十年，
过好啊，
体验好，
享受好就行了，
对不对，
不要过度内耗，
对吧,
该吃吃该喝喝，
然后该运动运动，
保持一个比较好的心态和身材就可以了，
我们讲的有点远，
再绕回来讲啊，
上期节目我看到有人讲说，
来的不少新厅友啊，
新厅友呢，
然后就觉得我这个人啊有点啰嗦，
然后讲话经常都是，
一会绕出去一会拉回来，
我想跟大家讲的就是啊，
我觉得这个风格啊，
我就这个风格，
因为我呢，
基本上就是一个提纲，
我就开始脱口秀去聊了，
呃,
大家看到的一些文字版本，
有的那是根据我的声音，
然后转文字去，
编辑在二次调整的，
那么也有一些是编辑先，
呃，我们一起把它，
大概给写好，
就是一些比较就数据不能错的地方给写好，
然后我再进行自由发挥，
因为你知道的播客如果是纯读稿子，
你就非常声音，
我做了十年年的播客了，
我是也曾经尝试过，
就是完全一个字一个字读的，
就完全不适合我，
所以我更喜欢是提纲啊，
或者是大提纲啊，
小提纲或者是大提纲啊，
都非常好玩，
因为我觉得播客本身是个很好玩的事情，
我也爱讲话嘛，
所以大家多多体谅啊，
我们再拉回来讲啊，
说说到哪儿了，
说到这个特斯拉帽德外的设计啊，
有前瞻七年都不怎么去换，
你要知道国内国产新增员，
国产新增员他基本上是，
一年就不能叫小改了，
就这一年的变化一定要非常的明显，
要不然没人买，
对不对，
因为为什么呢，
因为你不改，
隔壁的其他家在改，
甚至于我们之前聊过像极客，
极客001,
他恨不得一年换三代，
但是极客001，
我要给大家讲清楚，
那一次的一年换三代啊，
它是个特殊情况，
我曾经解释过，
就是说，
他呢一开始呢，
是想一次性进行大改的，
他首先是正好切中了，
一年期的这个小改款的时间周期，
相当于就是领导安排的任务，
那么这个小改款先给他改一遍，
改完之后呢，
他第二次改其实是，
他来不及了，
他第二次改是因为小米苏七，
马上就要上了，
然后小米跟吉利之间，
本身是有恩怨的，
为什么呢，
因为小米当时是把吉利的这个工程院，
老大那个团队直接给挖过来了，
所以吉利一直就非常对小米不爽，
那么他叫捷胡，
当时他的理解就是捷胡，
所以极客001其实大改款，
应该就是在后来的第三次，
所谓的换代的，
那个时候一次性上市的，
他中间跟第一次的那个小改款中间，
其实正好这个周期大概能隔个十个月左右，
那一般来讲，
客户是不会有什么意见的，
因为一年就十二个月嘛，
但是因为中间加了一次，
就为了去捷胡捷小米苏期，
所以就导致前面刚买的人就非常的不爽，
才几个月，
你又改款了，
然后后面第三次换代的人他也不爽，
他虽然让他买了，
他也不爽，
对吧,
所以这个东西怎么讲呢，
有的时候就是杀红了眼，
他也不顾一切了，
往往有些时候就是这样，
你不管是从企业的领导，
甚至于包括对吧，
我们讲以前这个民国时代，
我不知道当讲不当讲，
大家去看看历史就知道了，
很多的一些什么大领导人，
国家的大领导人，
就是赌气啊，
对吧,
你会发现他就是真什么东西，
就真个面子的问题，
其实说白了，
如果从利益角度，
或者说，
或者说从老百姓人民的利益角度来讲的话，
你根本就不应该做这件事，
说这句话，
执行这样一个动作，
但是你怎么讲呢，
你换做任何人，
你在那个时间点，
你会发现人是有血有肉的，
而且人在做任何一件事情，
你会觉得好像，
你事后去看，
你分析的都是头头石道的，
这个理论依据非常的充实的，
但是你在那个时间点，
你真的射身处地的，
那个夜晚，
跟身边的几个好兄弟一起去聊，
然后人家给你挑衅，
或者说不给你面子，
你的尊严被践踏，
你那个时候你就是要赌一口气嘛，
是不是，
所以特斯拉是什么概念呢，
特斯拉就跟国产性能源不一样，
它是属于叫做小改年年有，
所谓的小改就是给你，
这边加个按键，
那边去掉个按键，
屏幕换个档，什么的，
屏幕换档已经算大改了，
就是它小改年年有，
大改四五六，
什么叫大改四五六呢，
就是大改四年五年或六年，
然后换代七八九，
因为马上要换了嘛，
马上换的话就是七八九，
七年八年或九年是大换代，
所以特斯拉的这种玩法，
我觉得国内的车企，
它是根本模仿不起来的，
为什么模仿不起来，
我甚至于讲它想都不敢想，
是因为国产性能源是先跟，
咱们国产性能源打内战，
然后再跟特斯拉打外战，
对吧，你内战都打不过来，
你哪有时间去顾及这些，
对不对，
这个外来的敌人呢，
而且这个敌人说白了，
我不去杀他，
那别人也要杀，
是不是，
为什么要让我先动手呢，
为什么先要耗掉我的兵力呢，
为什么不能你先上啊，
对不对，
把你兵力消耗完了，
我再来消耗你不就行了吗，
所以就导致六家都在打他，
结果发现是六家各自打的各自，
特斯拉一家活得很，
特斯拉活得很，
所以哎呀，
真的是一个和尚有水喝，
对吧,
三个和尚就没水喝了，
那么全球第一，
那我们刚刚前面讲了，
其实它的这个400万的总量跟卡罗拉比，
还是差一点，
那当然了，
这个也是因为它这个毕竟是个很年轻的车企，
风田呢，
怎么讲的，
风田是卡罗拉1966年推出来的，
那么到今天为止12代，
就相当于换代换了12次了，
那么全球累计销量已经超过了5500万，
我的天呐，
这个应该能上解尼斯记录了啊，
它其实之前也去申请过，
也拿到过这个解尼斯记录，
不是这个5500，
当时是卖的多少万辆，
是卖的好像也是400万辆的时候，
申请了一次解尼斯记录，
那么它现在是5500万辆，
就是几乎是覆盖了全球的主流市场，
不管是从欧美到东南亚，
然后再到这个发达国家到发展中国家，
你都能看到卡罗拉，
那么更重要的就是什么呢，
就是卡罗拉，
我刚刚前面说到，
它其实代表的不是一辆车，
它,
你看上去是一辆车，
其实它背后代表的是风田那一套，
精益生产的逻辑，
很多人都听说过对吧，
风田精益生产，
精益生产这个逻辑，
其实对我的启发也很大，
我们家就有一本这个书，
当时是参加一个什么活动啊，
是一气风田的活动，
我记得啊，我想起来了，
我当时是参加那个汉南达的一个活动，
就是汉南达当时是想宣传，
就他们的质量非常好，
然后把那个汉南达拆开来，
把每个零部件拿出来给你看，
然后告诉你这个零部件，
国标是多少，
然后这个日本本土的标准是多少，
然后全球的标准是多少，
然后它是按照什么标准来生产的，
就想告诉你，
就是说它为什么那么耐用，
就是因为它在验证每一个零部件的这个环节上，
它不像，
它没有指名道姓啊，
反正它就是说它不像某些新势力的车企，
可能半年一年，
人家去试验几百万公里，
它可能就试验个一百万公里，
就直接就上了，
对吧，觉得没什么问题就直接上了，
所以这车的耐用性到底怎样，
这个就不得而止，
但是呢，就是卡罗拉或者说是风田的这一整套的制造逻辑，
其实是让它在全球市场非常受欢迎，
所以说燃油车的那个时代你可以理解为，
卡罗拉就是标干，
卡罗拉的这一套生产逻辑就形成了，
就是让其他的车企你想不想卖好，
你如果想卖好，
你就按照卡罗拉这个逻辑来，
便宜,
耐用,
省油,
稳定,
那么最终落到消费者这里就是神星嘛，
非常神星的一款车，
那么它形成那个正循环，
也正是因为大家对它的这个口味非常好，
全全球，
大家都觉得说买卡罗拉就什么也不用烦，
对吧,
只要去加玻璃水就行了，
定期保养就行了，
什么都不用管，
就修理厂老板都，
如果吃卡罗拉都得饿死，
因为修不了它的车，
一个卡罗拉一个马自达都是修不了对吧，
因为为什么呢，
因为不用修嘛，
不用修，
所以说，
全球的人民都是这样，
就是你要想买一辆带步车，
你不管是买一辆新的卡罗拉也好，
还是买一辆二手的也好，
你都不用担心，
那它前提是不要撞啊，
大家都知道日系车，
只要撞完之后再修，
它往往修出来这个效果，
就是你可能后面，
反复的就会出一些毛病，
但是德系车有的时候，
你修完之后它可能修的是，
虽然说它会有一些漏油渗油，
但是大问题没有，
小问题就小问题吧，
所以说卡罗拉的带名词，
就是稳定，
就是审刑，
卡罗拉就是买回来不出问题，
就是成本很低，
所以几乎就是燃油车时代的一个标准答案，
那么它就把这个能量就负能给其他的一些车型了，
你比方说，
像Ralf啊,
哈兰达啊，
你比方说像什么这个，
你包括像瑞治啊，
台美瑞啊这些，
你所有能提到的还包括赛娜，
就是你脑子里面，
只要能想到丰田的车系，
那每一个都稳了一塌糊涂，
它不是一个产品，
很耐用，
你比方说有些品牌，
它就有一个爆款，
但是那其他的车型或者某一款车型，
就出现了非常大的负面，
但是你看丰田是整个一套体系里面，
基本上是没有出现过，
非常严重的负面啊，
那么这里面问题就来了，
你说这么一个燃油车时代的标准，
最优解的一个车型，
那为什么非常短的时间内就被，
这个特斯拉的Model外给干掉了，
其实很简单，
我觉得不是特斯拉厉害，
也不是Model外厉害，
而是时代变了，
时事造英雄，
你可以这么理解，
就是你如果说，
丰田的卡罗拉是乍巴尼靠他的这个，
不管是从技术也好，
还是说从品牌也好，
一部一个脚印一点一点，
坑汁坑汁，
硬骨头坑过来的，
那你去理解特斯拉Model外，
成为全球的消贯，
那你就可以理解为，
它就是时事造英雄，
就像现在的网红，
跟以前的这种，
老的电视明星一样的，
以前老的电视明星是靠一部剧一部剧，
慢慢的慢慢的活起来了，
现在的网红是，
可能某一天晚上，
突然之间一夜之间，
刷了一下，
等一明天就把一个人给捧火了，
就像那个叫什么来着，
那个唱歌的那个叫什么，
叫郭友财，
对不对，
我到现在都百思不得其解，
这郭友财是怎么火的，
还有那个假笑教练，
说我有点阴谋，
我烦到朋友圈，
我有点阴谋，
也突然之间就火了，
我也不太了解，
但是这个社会本身，
它的这个人和人之间，
它的分层是非常非常割裂的，
你像这两天，
我女儿晚上写完作业了，
她说她要玩配音秀，
也不知道他们初中生，
怎么最近特别流行玩这个，
后来我就把我的那个，
因为我们家什么都缺，
就是不缺麦克风，
我就给了她一套非常专业的麦克风，
我给你拿她去录，
她说老爸这个录的效果真好，
然后呢，
她录完之后，
她把她的这个配音啊，
发到了小红书跟抖音上，
效果都不好，
结果呢，
她把它发到快手上，
她快手的效果就很好，
她每一条的这个视频逗音，
多的能有三四百个点赞，
四可能超四百没有啊，
就是少的也有几十个赞，
那她就形成了一个正反馈了，
因为她只要看到有赞，
有评论，
那人都是这样的嘛，
她就哎，
第二天她又去录，
第三天她又去录，
她如果天天只玩小红书跟抖音，
那发上去之后，
可能播放量都没超过一百，
那评论都是零，
点赞都是各位书，
她就没兴趣了，
是不是，
所以她是个正循环，
那么特斯拉其实在现在这个时代，
第一个，
那就是妥妥地吃了中国市场的红利嘛，
那就吃了这，
从头吃到尾嘛，
相当于是，
那么2012年大家可以看到，
全球市场其实电动车，
也是在做非常大的一个转变，
2012年全球纯电车的市场，
销量一共才十多万辆，
12年十四年前，
那么到了2025年就是去年，
全球行动员汽车的销量已经是2354.2万辆，
什么概念啊，
你说这个不是说翻十倍的概念了，
一百倍都不止了，
中国市场在2400万辆当中，
占到了将近70%，
按照这个统计数据来讲的话是70.3%，
所以你想想看，
新能源市场，
我们就讲中国新能源车市场，
6年时间，
从2020年到2026年，
或者说2029到2025吧，
它从市占率不到5%，
一直到市占率，
或者说是叫做渗透率，
它达到了60%，
十台车里面有将近6台车，
是新能源，
当然这里面有一大部分是网约车，
网约车也算，
但是你满大街能看到很多绿牌，
从我们对电动车萌萌咚咚咚，
然后到战战兢兢不太敢买，
然后再到义无反顾，
然后再到现在新池向往，
新池沉网，
你说我现在游车，
现在油价特别贵，
你看4月7号是不是又调价了，
油价特别贵，
而且这个调价还是在国家干预，
不让你大涨的情况下，
一路涨到现在，
马上都快95号油都快10块钱了吧，
对不对，
那我身边也发现很多的粉丝，
就想说刀哥，
我能不能去换电动车，
我觉得要慎重，
为什么我觉得要慎重，
今天萌萌咚外，
我就顺带聊聊我的观点，
你说你连油都加不起了，
你哪来的钱换车，
你说啊这五连免息，
对吧三连免息，
三连免息五连免息没错，
但是这钱不要还，
这钱不要还，
如果说你换这个车，
你举个例子，
旧车你卖掉，
你能回款，
回血格五六万块钱，
然后你买个新车，
你账上比方说再套个十万，
对吧十五万，
十五万，
十五万其实也买不到什么好的电动车，
好,
哪怕就是比亚迪，
吉利,
什么银河，
你能侧伙着开开，
行没问题，
买了这个车，
首先第一，
这个车的整体的质感，
不管是从空间，
还是从它的这种定位，
品质,
还是从你想要的，
甚至于你不想要它也给你的这些，
做以加热，
做以通风，
什么大屏幕这些，
是不是能够，
就是对于你旧车来讲，
是一种，
怎么讲呢，
就是史诗级的升级，
就是全都是你觉得，
让我的整个出行，
就是完完全全，
有一种质的飞越，
你觉得如果说有，
你只谈这个，
你不要去谈说我能省多少钱，
你省不了多少钱，
为什么这么讲，
因为你的那台旧车，
现在不是五六万卖掉吗，
你就算把它继续看下去，
你每一年的二手车折就折，
能折多少钱，
5000块钱,
你估计连5000都折不到了，
那么你现在买个15万的电动车，
第一年保守估计，
损13万块钱，
保底的吧，
是吧,
你今年再卖，
你卖出去12万，
13万,
我觉得正常行情吧，
是不是，
你,
而且现在要交勾支税，
以前还不交勾支税，
现在你15万的新的原车子的话，
你正常勾支税，
你就算折半去交的话，
你也要七八千，
你正常按100%交，
就是除以11.3，
你除以12，
再除以12，
就折半嘛，
对吧,
六七千，
六七千你还保险呢，
对吧,
七七八八算下来，
你还简单装个黄什么的，
贴个膜，
搞个脚垫什么东西的，
有的是送啊，
有的人觉得膜不好，
还要自己花钱，
所以你只要开个一两年一卖，
你肯定几万块钱就没有了，
那么你再往后的话，
那每一年的折就率都不低的，
而且电动车是，
电池用的越久，
公里数越多越不值钱，
到最后就不是这个车，
直播之前的问题了，
是你卖不出去，
是断牙式的下滑，
就越往后电池，
你想你作为买20车的人，
你看到它十几万公里了，
快20万公里了，
你说这车还能开，
电池的这个衰减没有多少，
对吧,
你看我虽然开了五六年，
电池原来能排过500多公里，
现在我还能跑个350公里，
300公里,
你觉得它信你吗，
它不信啊，
它觉得问题点在哪，
这不是300公里的问题啊，
是万一有一天，
突然我一脚电门，
这车不走了，
对吧,
然后提示报警，
电池包故障，
谁修啊，
我修啊，
那我要修，
你这个车子卖给我可能是几万块钱，
但是我修电池要花多少钱，
它就不值得修了，
最后是一堆废铁，
所以电动车到了后期，
是非常难卖的，
特别是开到个十来万公里，
特别是用了个五六年以后，
二车市场老板也不敢收，
你自己卖也非常难卖，
是这一点你想清楚了吗，
你想清楚了吗，
你当电车将来再把它卖掉的时候，
你算它的整个生命周期，
你比方说是五万买进来的，
然后你将来五万块钱卖出去了，
你中间这个十万块钱，
它整个生命周期是几年，
三年还是五年，
对吧,
你要把这个折损算进来之后，
你再去跟你现在的这个油车去比，
你这个油车如果再开五年呢，
你这个油车再开五年，
你没什么可损失的了，
那你那边亏十万，
你这边就亏个三万，
你中间差价亏七万，
这七万块钱五年还不够你加油啊，
我的天呐，
汽油不能烧饭，
人烧饭你打回家炒菜都可以了，
那绝对够你花了，
是不是就很多人算不清这笔上，
想买车就想买车，
我不说了嘛，
如果是冰箱采电搭沙发，
智能驾驶智能坐舱这些体验，
你觉得有质的飞跃，
条件上也允许该换就换，
我从来不可能拉着你说，
换个灯啊再等啊明年后年，
对吧,
等中期改款什么大改款等换戴，
有什么好等的，
有钱就花，
但如果说你不是现金流那么匆虑的人，
而且你本身还有很多地方要花钱，
你何苦被那么大的压力呢，
有这个必要嘛，
对不对，
你有赚法拉利的能力的钱，
这个资金量，
你去开一个也不说开奥托吧，
你开到奥迪，
我觉得你日子过的就非常潇洒了，
你说你就是一个开奥托的能力，
你只能挣到开奥托的钱，
你天天想开法拉利，
你不难受吗，
对不对，
幸福等于什么样，
就能力比上欲望嘛，
能力强欲望小，
那你肯定很幸福，
那你能力弱欲望又很强，
那你每天都生不如死，
而且你仇富，
你天天特别仇富，
看到谁有钱你都，
你恨不得，
我就不说了，
所以呢，
特斯拉帽多外其实说白了，
他把卡罗拉给一脚踹下来，
他其实从2020年开始交付，
到2023年夺得全球排名第一，
其实也就用了三四年，
我绝对不相信这三四年是这个产品力，
产品有多么的留白，
而是整个市场格局变了，
消费者的消费的欲望变了，
大家觉得说，
这个猫的外，
他就说对这个产品定义，
他不是一辆车，
他是一个时髦的产品，
时髦的玩具，
明星也在开，
对吧,
企业家也在开，
普通的这个工薪接族也在开，
就像我曾经讲的，
你说传统的机械表，
你带百达匪，
他带江湖弹盾，
你带个黑水鬼，
那我带个什么技嘉啊，
什么这些什么朗格啊，
那就每个人就是，
跟人的品味不同，
对不对，
但是大概能看得出来你的消费力是怎样的，
但是,
你现在都是带一个苹果手表，
你能看出个啥消费力啊，
但是我现在发现苹果的这个手表，
也多少也能看出来一点，
对吧,
你说你是S8，
S9,
S10,
我这个是个Ultra3，
那肯定啊，
UltraUltra3,。
万万一带手一台，
一看就知道，
旗舰版啊，
这哥们儿有钱啊，
我的天，
五六千啊，
嘿嘿嘿，
我们公司兔子不就是嘛，
兔子天天哭熊，
拿着苹果最新版的笔记本电脑，
带着苹果的UltraUltra3，
我都没有，
我都羡慕啊，
我每天，
我都兔子把你手表拿过来让我带一下，
老板,
你去买一块，
这个手表真的很好用，
我这个人就不太爱带表，
我说我就给你开个玩笑，
拿过来让我感受一下，
这个旗舰的苹果手机什么样的感觉，
他说真的非常好用，
不用看手机了，
我说我基本上从办公室路过啊，
就是你不是在刷手机，
就是在看电脑，
电脑当然是办公了，
嘿嘿嘿，
我说你这手机都不够看了，
你还带个手表看什么呢，
他说哎呦，
他说你带了就知道了，
肯定不一样，
我不带，
我对这个兴趣不是特别的大，
所以我就讲讲的，
就是有些时候，
他卖的是这个产品的体系，
它是一种感觉，
说白了，
还是拿那个iPhone去举例子，
不用iPhone举例子吧，
我就拿我的，
最近我准备去买那个，
人体工学椅，
我就拿这个人体工学椅，
去给大家举个例子啊，
你像国内的，
造的人体工学椅，
像最近有一个品牌，
广告打的特别多，
就那个叫清闲，
我到现在我都不知道，
那个到底好不好，
前两天我还在问那个科技小心，
我说你，
那么多的这个科技媒体都去，
都去评测都被充值，
怎么没充你啊，
他说再谈再谈，
他最近马上会拿一张椅子过来试一试，
对吧,
你看那个team，
就是那个叫什么影视剧风啊，
他不就是全公司配的都是那个吗，
还有那个，
合同学好像他们公司也都是配，
全都帮他站台，
明显是花了大价钱砸广告的嘛，
然后呢我最近在看稀号，
然后在看那个泳衣两家，
然后基本上差不多应该是考虑，
我想给公司啊，
就去买那个稀号，
但是你很有意思，
稀号它还分线上款跟线下款，
它线下款跟线上款不一样，
然后呢前段时间我就问我朋友，
我说哎，
我说你们家那个电脑椅用的是什么，
他说我们家用的是，
鹤麦米勒，
我说这一听就是个养品牌，
我说这，
电脑椅还有进口的，
他说你看就不懂了吧，
他说鹤麦米勒，
百年品牌，
说这个牌子好，
然后呢我再往上搜了一下，
哇这个电脑椅，
我那天我就说了，
我说兄弟啊，
你平时都是以普通人的身份跟我们相处，
结果一个电脑椅就把你给出卖了，
我说你们家这个电脑椅一万多块钱啊，
他说是啊，
一万多块钱买个电脑椅不正常吗，
他说也没有那么贵，
他说你给你买个普通版本的，
七八千的也有，
我说我的预算都没超过六百块钱，
他说七八千块钱也有，
我想讲的是什么意思呢，
就是首先你的消费力跟这个产品本身它要对等，
然后其次就是这个椅子在网上我也看了很多的口碑，
特别特别好玩，
就是说国产的这些叫做这个人体工学椅啊，
它的设计逻辑就是，
我不管你身体是直着做也好，
还是弓着腰去做也好，
你是想躺下来睡一会也好，
在办公室午休也好，
还是说这个你想按个摩或者怎样啊，
或者稍微有点点厚养也好，
它是贴合你的骨骼，
或者说它就像你的这个脊椎一样分成一层一层的一格一格的，
然后去贴合你的骨骼，
甚至是动态的、摇摆的去贴合的，
但这里面有个逻辑的悖论，
就是人体工学椅，
它本质上来讲到底是纠正你错误的作姿，
还是说去迎合你，
让你在你哪怕错误的情况下就比较多，
扩这个腰，
弯这个腰去办公的时候，
让你也变得很舒服，
它到底是以哪个为标准，
哎有点意思，
我最近在研究这个椅子的时候，
我发现评论区的人才特别多，
他说赫曼米勒这种椅子，
他做了真的是将近百年的这个企业了，
他这个椅子一坐上去就感觉屁股是紧繃的，
因为他的那个，
他那个叫什么支部还是支网什么东西的，
就是特别密，
然后也是一种特殊材质，
然后靠背也是笔直的，
你坐上去第一感觉就是这个椅子不舒服，
但是你坐久了，
但是他也有很奇怪，
他在网上也有三四千的，
有人说是假的，
没有那个SN码，
我也不敢买，
然后呢，
就叫ARONAU,。
就是A-E-R-O-N-ARONAU,。
二代ARONAU,。
然后正常的话官方店都是一万多，
同款,
然后有人讲那个三千多的就是，
大腿可能做酒会有点发麻，
然后有个人两个都买了，
去评测，
关于也是够下血本的，
然后那个一万多的那个版本，
做了时间久了大腿不会发麻，
但是他的这个设计逻辑就是，
让你是以标准的作姿，
去保持这样一个状态去办公，
但是国内就不是的，
国内的椅子到了高端那个系列，
什么500C的系列，
还能躺倒，
还能电动按摩，
还可以加热窝的天哪，
热敷什么都有，
所以你看，
造车跟造椅子我觉得就非常的像，
就是你到底是以什么样的定位和逻辑来，
是迎合消费者的需求，
你想要什么我就给什么，
还是说我就觉得我认定的东西是对的，
就是对的，
你既然是办公，
你长时间服务工作，
那你就是应该正常的作姿，
比值的作姿，
或者说相对比较值的作姿，
只能给你一点点的移动的空间，
而不是说，
让你能够想弯腰就弯腰，
想低头就低头，
哪个逻辑是对的，
我们评论区也可以交流一下嘛，
所以这就导致到今天为止，
我这个办公仪还没买，
我在想我到底要不要去喂，
喝半米乐这个一万多去买单，
是不是至伤税，
还是说我就花个三五千块钱去买个500C，
啊,
稀号那个什么500C，
兄弟们有没有懂这个行业的，
甚至你就是卖这个，
叫什么电脑仪的，
对吧,
你能不能联系我，
联系顿买跟我聊一下，
真的我就非常迷惑，
非常疑惑，
那么车骑士也是一个道理嘛，
对不对，
那你说造车，
你特别是造电动车，
它的正常的逻辑是冰箱，
彩链,
大沙发吗？
还是说就像特斯拉这样，
就是极致简单，
但是你该有的功能，
其实核心功能它也都有，
导航,
听歌,
喜马拉雅，
这些东西听书它都有，
它还有什么东西做不到呢，
无非就是语音稍微的麻烦一些，
现在语音也在优化，
导航地图也在优化，
这些东西对它一讲也不难，
只不过它作为一个外商独自的企业，
在中国这套流程里面，
它相对来讲做的这个迟迟性啊，
就是稍微动作会慢一点，
但是它不是做不好，
是不是，
你说老外什么车机程序做不好，
你说老外这个软件做不好，
这怎么可能呢，
那国内的很多软件公司的软件都是抄的国外的，
现在不能叫抄，
叫真流，
都是真流国外的，
所以现如今这个电动车，
它其实是用造手机的逻辑来造车，
雷军已经看得很透了，
那么马斯克其实很早就已经看出来了，
因为我曾经讲过马斯克的这个故事，
你想马斯克当年造电动车最早的逻辑是什么，
因为这公司本来不是他的，
这个公司本来就是两个，
就是最早最早做电子书的，
他比亚马逊做Kindle还要再早，
叫Rocket,。
叫火箭电子书，
大家在网上现在还能收得到，
我还看过那个图片，
那个造型就跟Kindle的那个造型特别像，
不应该这么讲，
Kindle我不知道是不是抄他的，
如果他先出Kindle后出，
那我觉得大概率是抄他的，
所以特斯拉公司原来最早是两个做这个叫做电子书的，
这个老板把公司卖掉之后财富自由了嘛，
然后呢去搞了这么个特斯拉，
然后马斯克进来了，
然后马斯克把他们踢掉了，
然后成为老板对吧，
马斯克其实看到了这个电子书里面的这个理电池，
他就当时设想有没有可能把他拿过来去做汽车，
而且中间还有一段经历是什么，
是有人想做纯电的飞机，
想让马斯克去投资，
因为他财富自由了嘛那个时候，
财富自由之后呢，
有人想问他要钱去做这个投资做企业，
那么有一个人是做这种纯电的飞机，
或者说是混动的飞机，
那马斯克当时就在想说，
左手边是电子书，
右边是飞机，
那电池为什么不能去坐车呢？
而且我曾经也讲过，
马斯克当年在上大学的时候选的专业，
也是跟电相关的，
也是跟电池储能相关的，
所以就很多的一些因素把他拼凑在一起，
就让他形成了这样的一个企业，
或者说这样的一个想法，
都说他是狂人，
但是我觉得狂不狂本质上来讲，
人的认知总归是有限的，
他这一辈子走的这些路，
往往就想讲，
今天我看微博有个热搜叫做，
什么教育是有持久性跟迟迟性的，
然后后来我就调侃了一句，
我说对，教育是有持久性和迟迟性的，
但是补课的费用是一分钱不会给你少的，
而且你晚一天交的不会给你上，
你补课的钱是一分都不能少的，
因为我们家刚交了补课的钱，
我的天呐，大出血啊，
所以造电动车的本身逻辑，
就是跟造手机电子产品就非常的像，
那么汽车从复杂的一种机械组装，
那现在把它要变成一个极致的电子集成的一个设备，
其实马斯克的所有的逻辑都是这样，
就是能让他尽量的减化就减化，
能让他尽量自动化，
就自动化，
人为的这种干预尽量要少，
然后把它的底层逻辑想清楚，
也就是第一性原则，
让它稳定，
让它不出问题，
如果是电动车的话就让它尽量的去审电，
让它的尽量的长续航，
让它尽量的保持一致性，
电池电量一致性，
所以很多人会发现，
特斯拉的续航它不一定那么长，
但是它说多少是多少，
它不管是表显也好，
还是说它实际的这种续航的达成率也好，
让大家开的时候心里面是比较踏实的，
这个有意说一啊，
有意说一，
而且你买到手之后你将来再卖，
特斯拉那绝对是在二手电动车市场里面，
保值率是属于数二的，
你说对不对，
所以Model外这款产品是属于，
你如果看了一圈所有的国产性能源，
包括特斯拉之后，
你实在不知道自己要买什么车，
你往往其实心里面会在想，
买特斯拉它是不会有错的，
我曾经也讲过这么一句话，
我说很多人是先买特斯拉，
后买电动车，
它是先任何特斯拉，
后任何电动车，
你包括很多小姑娘，
它其实对电动车没有概念，
但它就认识特斯拉，
就这么简单一件事，
你包括前两天我老婆跟我讲说，
原来加一箱油两三百，
现在加一箱油要四五百，
好说我现在真的油都开不起了，
我说油都开不起，
那就换电车，
那你问他买什么电车，
他也说不上来，
他都报不出几个电车的名字，
绕来绕去我就问他这个行不行啊，
那个行不行啊，
这个不好看，
那个牌子没听过，
然后最后就是特斯拉，
你给他一看特斯拉，
可以啊可以啊，
没问题啊，
买个特斯拉可以啊，
但是不行，
老公我一定要新的，
我不要旧的，
他一定要新的不要旧的，
所以你看，
他不问你功能，
不问你配置，
他甚至都不问你空间，
洞里什么东西，
他都不要，
你给他讲这个特斯拉行了，
我就要，
我买了，
那你说，
我给他推个比亚迪，
什么意思啊？
不是老公你说清楚，
你什么意思，
你为什么要给我买比亚迪，
你为什么，
他甚至都不会问你，
你给他买比亚迪哪一款车，
这款车多少钱，
我说我给你买个比亚迪腾饰，
我给你买个比亚迪仰望，
后面的这些都不重要，
重要的就是，
老公你为什么要给我买比亚迪，
你是觉得，
我就配开比亚迪吗，
你是对我的爱不够多吗，
还是说，
这个叫什么，
你最近，
这个经济上出问题了，
公司要倒闭了，
你给我买比亚迪，
我讲的可能有点夸张啊，
但是你可以试一试，
跟你媳妇讲，
你说媳妇把你车卖了，
那我不说比亚迪不好，
就没有任何，
就是羽蛮又有人讲说我看不起比亚迪了，
我举个例子，
那不行换成吉利，
你给我给你买个吉利，
那我老婆肯定也有意见啊，
说你给我买什么吉利啊，
我为什么要开吉利啊，
我不要开啊，
就是我想讲的，
这个意思打来听懂啊，
听话要听音啊，
就听话不要光听字面意思，
要去听音，
你跟人聊天也是这样，
听话听音，
就是说，
特斯拉他赢的是赢在一个体系，
而不是赢在一个产品，
我曾经跟很多的这些，
车企的高管也聊过这个事，
因为我会参加很多车型的一个，
内部的定义啊，
包括营销的定义的这种会，
那么在这个会里面，
他们经常也会问说，
啊我们怎么怎么能够，
销量,
他们没有说赶超啊，
就是尽量，
市场份额更高一点，
或者说我们这款产品，
大老板，
期望值还是非常高的，
我就问他，
那你一个月定的销量大概是多少，
我说,
我都不敢讲，
我怕到时候我讲了，
他们几个领导在一起又难看，
我大概是多少，
那几个领导，
你看看我，
我看看你，
说,
一万,
我当时也不是说一万不行，
我说这一万是，
你从预定就是这个，
开定之日起开始算，
就一直保持一万，
还是说先给你们大概六个月的时间，
啊先看一看市场的反馈，
啊如果不行就调价，
如果不行就再放权益，
然后慢慢的稳定在一万，
这是两种概念，
他说我们，
我们预售就要保持一直在一万，
他说等我们产能上来，
我们希望这个产品能额卖到，
两万,
我说啊，
如果是按照这样的来讲的话，
那我们前面就得要重新再聊一聊了，
对吧,
那你这个产品的配置也好，
价格也好，
你就不能这么定了，
那结果呢，
财务总监旁边坐着，
价格也不给改，
然后配置也不让动，
但是销量就一定要一万两万，
那你,
又要马而跑，
又要马而不吃草，
那大环境就在这儿，
对不对，
不是说单个产品，
你觉得你很强，
你就一定能卖得出去，
这个事情已经被无数次的验证了，
你包括当年的国产的这个燃油车，
不也是无数次被验证了嘛，
你光有配置有什么用啊，
你产品体系，
包括对于用户的决策的这个周期，
和那种信任程度都不一样，
很多东西都是感性的，
它不是理性的，
就像国产的这些机器，
国产的手机，
你跑个分那都是狂高无比啊，
但是你实际体验呢，
那苹果的那种，
软件的操作的丝滑程度，
封闭的系统不会有那种无锡八刀的软件，
去干扰，
不会跳出小广告，
对不对，
它每一个细节的那种把控，
它就用的舒服，
所以我就喜欢办公啊，
主力机我就用一个iPhone，
哪怕它就是不能双开微信，
到今天为止我觉得iPhone唯一的八个点，
就是不能双开微信，
所以我在想将来它那个双折叠，
它妈不是要出双折叠了吗，
它如果双折叠能够双开微信，
那闭着眼睛直接入啊，
这还用想嘛，
因为双开微信就可以，
另外一个手机就不用了，
不行,
安卓机还是要留一个，
因为有些软件确确实实是需要安卓机来安装的，
兄弟们懂的都懂的啊，
但是我们如果把这个视野啊，
或者视角再放大一点，
我们从特斯拉的这个角度去看，
特斯拉其实做了一件传统车企很难做的事情，
他就是把所有的这些生产流程啊，
就是极致的标准化，
包括把它的车型配置也是极致的标准化，
所以它这个产品就非常的简单，
它的所有的产品就是或者说品牌表达出来的这种语言，
也非常的简单啊，
你的决策也非常的简单，
你的使用也非常的简单，
甚至于你的售后也非常的简单，
就一切都是简单中的简单，
就是傻瓜，
它所有的这些逻辑，
它背后有一套可能是很复杂的算法，
或者说是都是全球最顶尖的一些人才，
去定义它的产品，
去设计它的产品，
但是最终，
它给你感觉就是拿到手的这个东西，
就是一个非常简单，
上手就会用的，
就像我们讲说苹果为什么会让大家那么欢迎，
苹果你说因为是触屏，
你这样子想，
你注意看啊，
我们有的时候去逛那些熬虫乐园，
你会发现这个妈妈呢，
为了让小孩不哭不闹，
丢了一个iPad给她，
或者丢了个手机给她，
那个小朋友连画都不会讲，
连画都不会讲，
他就能拿一根手指在上面划，
划,划,
你不管他看视频也好，
还有一些游戏，
也是只要一根手指就可以点一点就能玩的，
他都会玩，
对不对，
你说当年在这种按键手机上，
能玩的了吗？
按键手机到经典为止，
按键手机我唯一能想到的玩的游戏，
就是那个探视蛇，
对吧,
你可以用那个123456789，
你不停的在上面按探视蛇，
还记得吗，
以前用那个洛基亚去玩那个探视蛇，
对不对，
你唯一能让我想到就是这个游戏，
但是你现在一根手指头，
你就可以在那边划，
极致简单，
但是背后的逻辑其实是很复杂的，
你包括我曾经也讲过这么一个案例，
Windows的系统出故障，
它是会出现一个蓝色的屏幕，
然后上面有一段很复杂的英文，
它是默认，
你会去找一个电脑工程师来帮你去修电脑，
而不是让你作为消费者，
你具备修复电脑，
或者是修复软件的能力，
但是苹果的产品逻辑就是，
我为什么那么傻叉的要让一个用户去看到一个蓝色的屏幕上面一堆英文呢？
对不对，
我就不应该让它死机，
或者说如果真的出现一个bug了，
让它重启一下能不能就好呢，
所以苹果很少会出现这个吧，
我反正我是没见过苹果说出现这种，
它有的时候会卡的话就关个机，
重新开机不就好了嘛，
对不对，
偶尔卡死一下，
但是整体来讲系统还是非常稳定的，
但是其实现在Windows也很稳定，
因为我现在电脑就是笔记本就是Windows，
到今天为止，
用了这么多年了，
我到现在没有什么突然重启黑屏的司机，
没有,
我觉得我就电脑挺好用的，
虽然说挺重的，
就是我这个是汇普的暗影精灵，
那我们继续往下讲，
其实特斯拉包括它的生产效率，
生产效率一体化的压住，
包括它的电池也是字眼，
芯片也是字眼，
然后整个供应链体系也是高度的整合，
所以特斯拉的产品它是，
整个成本不断的在往下降，
它的销量不断的往上涨，
然后整个成本往下降，
然后你会发现，
它往下降完之后，
它卖的越多，
它的价格越便宜，
它的价格是跟它成本走的，
这家企业很有意思，
我估猜它的定价都是跟那个，
这个忠实话忠实有异样，
就是根据这个原油价格的上下调整，
对吧,
所以呢，
这个产品从2020年，
大家还记得吗，
当时2020年首批进口的帽子外，
在国内卖多少钱，
长驱航起售价是48.8万，
然后高性能版，
就是市区的起售价是53.5万，
那么到了2021年，
当时是第一批国产的帽子外上市，
那么在上海生产的，
那么长驱航的市区版本的定价是33.99万，
33.99万什么概念，
就一下子降了十几万，
然后到了今天，
2026年,
现在的这个长驱航的市区版，
就是全轮驱动版，
只卖到了31万3500，
也是降了2万多块钱，
那么它的入门版本，
就是后轮驱动版，
只要26万3500，
还没完啊，
还没完，
26万3500,。
你如果不想选全款付的话，
你只要付个首付，
799000,
然后五年免息，
所以卖的便宜，
它还能有签证，
这就是特斯拉最牛查的点，
因为国内很多的产品，
现在卖的也很便宜，
但是你拿出厂家的这个财务数据的话，
那都在亏钱，
它现在基本上单车的毛利率，
能够维持在15%到18%上下，
很多的新能源车，
现在杀到最后，
杀到已经毛利率都不到5%，
5%上下,
所以5%跟15%是什么概念，
你要知道企业跟企业之间的竞争，
一到两个点可能都是生死存亡，
你别跟别人说10个点了，
所以这个就是很恐怖的一件事情，
大家不是一直都讲嘛，
说整个目前新能源车系里面，
或者说只要是不卖游车，
只卖新能源的车系里面，
现在目前能挣钱的就两家嘛，
一个特斯拉，
一个是比亚迪嘛，
所以特斯拉其实不是说它的产品有多牛，
而它整个的这一套语言，
以及它背后的这套体系，
还是非常非常牛白的，
还是非常牛白的，
上海工厂基本上它的交付量，
应该能占到全球特斯拉的，
总交付量的52%，
因为上海本身这个工厂，
这个知识的力度也很高嘛，
然后在中国整体来讲，
不管是建厂的效率，
还是生产的效率都非常高，
我曾经看到一个数据说什么，
说一周的产能能达到2.5，
接近3万辆，
我的嘛，
一周七天，
2.5万辆,
什么概念啊，
大家还记得之前小米苏七，
一直交不上货的时候，
当时有人拍了一张照片，
就是那个小米苏七生产线上的那个，
什么今日产量多少台的，
我不知道是真实讲，
当时那个数字是多少，
是500多还是多少的，
如果是510天5000一个月1万，
不是一个月1万，
就是如果按一周来讲的话，
一周三千，
一周三千和一周两万五，
就单从产能上来讲，
就极度夸张，
极其夸张，
我记得有一年我看到，
特斯拉当时工厂的产能规划是50万一年，
50万一年什么概念，
一个月才四万多台，
一个月四万多台，
划到一周的话大概是1万多台，
如果现在把它干到2万5，
那不就翻了一倍多嘛，
应该是两个工厂，
可能枯建之后的整体产能，
然后拉到报之后，
拉报,
因为它有段时间产能切换，
产能切换之后呢，
中间就，
就是一下子销量就拉跨了嘛，
拉跨之后，
然后开始为了去补它之前，
缺失的功课，
就不停的分好地生产，
对吧,
在中国反正加班这个，
又没有工会，
加班你给钱不就行了嘛，
对不对，
你给钱就行了嘛，
哎呀,
所以我们怎么讲呢，
我们回过头来讲嘛，
就是像猫豆外这个车型，
它成为全球消贯，
其实这个是表面看，
是一台车它赢了，
一台电车去赢了，
像游车卡罗拉，
但本质上来讲，
我觉得是，
两个时代的逻辑的一个交替，
卡罗拉是燃油时代的最优点，
那猫豆外它也许不是电动车时代最好的车，
但很有可能在很多人的眼里，
电动车等于特斯拉，
特斯拉等于电动车，
它是适合这个时代的车，
对吧,
而且按照全球的知名度来讲的话，
应该没有任何一个品牌，
它的知名度能跟特斯拉相提并论，
这个玩意又讲到题外话了，
前两天我们有一个听友，
你再跟我聊一件事情，
他跟我说，
他说海外其实在招商的过程当中，
很多的国外的经销商，
他其实不是顾虑你中国的产品卖不出去，
也不是顾虑你中国产品质量不行，
他顾虑的就是你在我们这个市场能开多久，
你怎么保证它的售后，
你怎么保证你突然有一天领导一派老代说，
我退出这个市场，
我不在这里干了，
对吧,
特斯拉这个品牌，
它不管进入到哪个市场，
它其实整个打法和体系，
它是一步一步往前去推进的，
所以这种信任的成本，
或者说我曾经讲过，
你如果是中国的车旗去出海，
最好是形成一个同盟，
因为我们是一致去海外去抢蛋糕的，
不至于说你多抢了我少抢了，
就大家都是从零开始做，
但是结果是什么，
就是这一条最繁华的街道上，
开一家来两家，
开两家来三家，
中国品牌在最繁华的比方说什么德国，
意大利的某个市中心闹市区的旁边，
开了一排豪华的店，
结果呢？
结果高河倒掉了，
高河我印象最深，
高河说是在德国穆尼黑机场，
就在机场旁边，
就拿了一个门面，
那天还有人去拍的，
国内已经高河不生产了，
那边的门面店还开着，
巨大的一个店里面，
就放了一两辆车，
还有包括长城，
之前也是在海外，
说收缩战略也不开了，
旁边就是一个未来的店，
你中国品牌今天倒一个，
明天撤一个，
后天再关一个，
那在老外的眼里，
不管是从老外的经销商的眼里，
还是从老外的消费者的眼里，
他会怎么想？
所以这也是个问题，
所以不要看到新闻里面天天讲说，
中国车只不过你没给我们开放市场，
你只要开放了市场，
我们中国车学习全球，
我当然我相信，
我相信中国的品牌的，
这个竞争力会非常的强，
但是无论是从它的语言，
就设计语言，
它的产品的定义，
你包括整体的营销策略，
那包括，
我们能不能报报团，
我们能不能，
对吧,
携手去抢海外市场，
先放下大家之间的恩怨，
大家的隔阂，
有没有一个老大能站出来？
那么最后想问，
如果有个老大站出来，
去带领我们国内这么多的企业，
一起去形成一个小的团体，
去抢海外市场，
你觉得国内的哪个车企老大，
最适合当这个，
叫什么来着，
武林盟主，
你觉得谁适合当武林盟主？
名字我就不说了，
大家猜一猜，
大家想一想吧，
我觉得我心中有这么一个人，
看看我们想的是不是一样的，
行,
那以上就是本期节目所有的内容，
给大家收听，
主要内容，
感谢大家收听，
那么接下来是关于上期节目的留言互动，
那么每期节目，
我们会抽取三位，
评论区，
我会跟大家做个互动，
那么每一位会获得由任严计，
提供的预录箱离试试装，
试试装里面有5颗，
非常好吃，
大家如果想买这个预录箱离，
也可以上我们的小程序，
微信小程序，
搜索摆车全说就可以了，
还有我们的品牌的周边都是有售的，
那么同时，
大家如果说想要去联系我，
也可以加微信46415254，
那么上期节目，
我们聊的是齐睿可控何去变，
要做可控何去变，
很多人讲说，
刀哥你要是没车可聊，
你就不要聊，
你休息一天，
你竟扯这些毒子有什么意义呢？
扯毒子干嘛呢你这是？
我这是扯毒子吗？
首先,
我觉得这就挺有意义的，
我觉得挺好玩的，
至少我长知识了，
我搜索资料的时候，
我以后跟人聊天，
我不就知道可控何去变是啥了吗？
对不对？
对吧?
你再学我也再学，
我们互相再学习嘛，
那其次这不是车吗？
那有朝一日等到真的有人开始给你吹牛皮可控何去变的时候，
对吧?
厂家在跟你说的时候，
那他说得对不对？
靠不靠谱？
你最起码，
你源头上的知识来源在我这儿，
那我跟你说的东西是我筛选过的，
我觉得是没啥问题的，
是不是？
很多人说不爱停，
我不爱停，
我就要停车，
那等我聊车了吧，
我聊个30万的，
你说我只想了解老百姓买这些的车，
你别天天说那么多贵的，
然后我再说个10万的吧，
然后人家又说刀哥你别聊10万的，
有什么意义啊？
我从来不看这些车，
在我们家50万引力的车我都不看，
能不能聊点好点的车？
那么多新车你不聊，
你是不是不敢聊啊？
是不是厂家给你充值了，
你不敢说坏话？
我就是那个爷爷带孙子，
岂是毛女的人，
这岂也不是则也不是，
把驴扛在身上也不是，
反正怎么都不是，
还有人把着我以前讲过的话，
自媒体不挣钱，
音明不挣钱，
我一共就讲过那么几次，
天天就我都忘了，
你还记在心里，
就老和尚跟小和尚过河一样，
对吧,
抱了一下那个小美女过河，
老和尚都已经忘了，
小和尚还念念不忘，
对吧,
你是把他放下了，
但你在心里面里面放下，
但也有人玩又讲了，
有人就讲说，
道哥,
那讲就给他讲呗，
你总是留言区里面，
你就看那几个讲的不好的，
就说明什么，
说明你在意，
那我也是忍爱，
也是吃五穀杂粮的，
当然了，
你这个刺眼的那种评论，
肯定是第一眼就能看到嘛，
那还有人就讲了，
说那你想过没有，
有些人他就是为了，
引起你主播的注意，
所以他就是，
发的这个言论就特别刺激，
那就是刺激你这个主播的，
哎呀,
这个城市套路多，
真的,
我想回农村啊，
但是挺好玩的，
挺好玩的，
上期听有，
第一位叫做，
R-M-O-R-E-O,。
R-V-O,
他说道哥，
你这个动起来之前，
能不能给我们多录点节目啊，
因为上期节目我讲，
我说我真的想看看，
百年以后何居面，
能不能真的实现啊，
我说我不行，
把我自己给动起来，
也不要多动个50年，
或者动个100年，
对吧,
然后将来我再苏醒过来，
我来看一看未来的世界，
让这哥们跟我讲，
他说如果道哥你动起来之前，
能不能多录点节目，
以后啊，
我跟你讲啊，
以后不要多录节目了，
以后呢，
就在那个墓碑上面啊，
印个二维码，
然后这个二维码呢，
背后啊，
它是一个clo的龙虾，
什么意思呢，
因为我的声音现在不是已经是被简印，
就是商业化运用了嘛，
对吧,
那么简印大家在简节目的时候，
就可以用我的声音了，
那么,
我在,
用AI去,
就是设计一套程序，
对吧,
让它有一个scale，
就是直接去抓取，
最新的新闻，
汽车新闻资讯，
然后自动生成一篇音频稿，
然后通过我的声音，
那不就播出来的嘛，
对不对，
以后大家想听我的节目，
就直接在网上扫目嘛，
我做一个我的主页，
主页都有了嘛，
3w.autotalk.cn,。
这就是我的官网，
这个官网以后，
我给它充100年的费用不就行了嘛，
这服务器就给它充100年，
大家直接上这个官网，
扫一下二维码，
那都是最新的汽车资讯啊，
你就一直关注嘛，
对吧,
你不但关注完了，
给你儿子也关注，
儿子关注完了，
孙子也关注，
对吧,
子子孙孙都在听百尺全说，
而且每一期节目都是最新的，
每期节目都是我的声音，
永远保持这个声音，
人都已经不在这个世上100年了，
诞成100周年了，
我的天哪，
我想想都有点毛骨悚然啊，
哎呀,
其实我觉得是这样的，
就,
哎,
我觉得，
有一个片子叫什么来着，
就是讲那个，
就是西班牙还是哪儿啊，
有一个节，
是巴西还是西班牙，
就是那个，
请记住我，
就那首歌，
毛布易唱的那首歌，
那叫什么，
那什么片子的，
说这个，
当你的亲人，
不在既得你的时候，
那你就真正在这个世界上消失了，
所以大家最近也是在扫目，
我也在思考这个问题，
对吧,
就人活着的意义是什么，
包括人真正离开这个世界了，
子子孙孙，
其实他跟你之间的这种连接，
到底是什么，
每一年就扫个目吗，
对吧,
还是说，
扫目,
其实我觉得也就走个行事，
他对你的思念，
到底体现在什么样的一个场景下，
哎呀,
这个东西有的时候啊，
就不能多想，
想的那都是行而上的，
实际做的呢，
都是眼前的，
下一位听有，
叫做简单就好啊，
简是简单的简单呢，
是那个丹阳的丹，
辽东啊，
是辽宁吗，
丹东的丹，
他说,
刀书,
对不对，
刀书啊，
你比我小几岁就喊我刀书了，
他说,
刀书你好，
其实呢，
你可以把知识星球作为抽奖，
送给大家，
如果想要知识星球的会员，
你可以选择这个，
如果不想要，
那你就可以选择预录相离嘛，
哎,
我觉得可以，
这个倒提醒我了，
那真的是可以把知识星球送给大家，
知识星球的费用，
我觉得比预录相离可能还要贵一点，
那么知识星球的话是这样的，
其实如果你不是知识星球的话，
我送你，
你可以直接开通嘛，
那如果说你识知识星球的，
就已经在知识星球里面，
你可以再给你免费蓄意念嘛，
对不对，
众一次讲免费蓄意念嘛，
但是你要如果这样的话，
那我这个小九九，
我真的这点这个零花钱，
岂不是又少了，
我来考虑考虑，
问题不大，
大家觉得呢，
想要知识星球的会员吗，
评论区可以告诉我，
好,
第三位挺友，
他的名字叫做王喵喵在睡觉，
他说,
做自媒体啊，
真的是需要一颗强大的心脏，
要面对各种不一样的声音，
上一期三刀二辽章选的故事，
其实我对于汽车，
这个摩托车这种机械设备，
我一点都不感兴趣，
但是呢，
哎,
我一边做家务，
我一边听，
我就觉得，
我就喜欢听三刀的声音，
还是一种雨调，
然后呢，
这个动不动黑黑一笑啊，
我觉得挺有意思的，
他说我自己的生活也是奇奇浮浮，
那么听了章选的这个故事呢，
其实可以把它当成是一个，
这个小人物立志的一个故事，
对自己呢，
也是有参考有价值的部分，
那么自媒体的内容那么多，
如果说我感兴趣的，
我就听一听，
那如果我不感兴趣的，
我不认同的，
那我就默默地把他关掉就行了，
没有必要，
一定要在评论区里面表达说我不喜欢，
其实这也是对作者的一种尊重吧，
他说以上就是我的个人观点，
对,
是一种尊重，
有的时候我也很矛盾啊，
就是说，
如果评论区一片响合，
大家都说三刀好三刀好，
你好我好大家好，
那说明什么，
说明你这个账号啊，
他不长粉了，
对不对，
都是一帮老兄弟，
老朋友过来给你捧捧场，
那么人情事故的，
你不管讲的好语不好，
大家都会在评论区给你喝喝彩，
但是这个评论区里面，
开始出现不同的声音了，
甚至你明显发现，
这个声音在往年根本就不会出现，
我举个例子，
你比如说小宇宙，
上期节目，
我当时提到了张雪的老婆，
当时说的啥来着，
我都记不得了，
我说张雪的老婆喜欢写日记，
然后张雪在外面借了他们家什么，
姑妈姨妈奶奶，
妈妈的钱，
然后亲人帮她一起怎么怎么地，
然后我说，
张雪老婆一看就是个闲内住，
对吧,
有人打理她的后方，
张雪可以义无反顾地去创业，
好像啊对，
好像我还提到了，
我说人要什么无德无财无根是吧，
是上次讲的吗，
我记得，
我当时讲的这些，
讲完之后，
我就看到小宇宙那边啊，
就有一些这个，
女性的听友在评论，
然后有些听友的意思就是说，
如果男人足够贤惠的话，
女人也可以亿万无钱，
亿无反顾，
如果男人足够贤惠，
我觉得他讲的有道理啊，
我觉得有道理，
真的有道理啊，
然后还有人讲是什么来着，
说什么啊这个一听就是个什么，
什么老灯啊，
什么大男子主义啊，
反正就讲我就是意思，
没有顾及到女性的这个听友，
说句实在话，
我的听友里面女性用户的占比，
可能都不及5%，
真的10%是绝对不可能的，
我的女性的听友的占比应该是不及5%，
那我在讲话的过程当中，
我是想到哪说到哪，
我确实这个是个直男的性格，
我说句实在话，
很多的女生可能不太喜欢我的性格，
是不是有些人觉得说，
啊三刀你这么能讲，
一定很受女生欢迎吧，
我跟你讲我从小，
我发现我身边特别，
特别是美女都不喜欢我这种类型，
就是嘴上话太多，
不喜欢，
而且这个一看就很精明，
在你的身上占不到便宜的这种类型，
但女生都不喜欢我这种类型，
女生喜欢那种闷闷的，
哎就是，
怎么讲呢，颜值要有对吧，
身高要有，
然后又闷闷的，
就私底下两个人，
就啊不知什么讲，
不知甚不知其连两个人，
小手就牵起来了，
小嘴就牵起来了，
所以我们见太多了，
像我这种一点心事都装不到心里面的人，
一点小动静那全世界都知道的，
对吧你随着年龄大了，
现在稍微好一点了，
以前我是嘴上装不住事，
脸上装不住事，
真的我都是，
整个人心里是装不住事情的，
我什么事情都想跟人分享，
所以你后来不就都自媒体了吗，
天生自媒体身体啊，
对吧就这么一个人，
你我也不想改变，
也没有必要改变，
活得真实一点也挺好，
我不伤害你，
对吧大家呢就也尽量少伤害我，
那我目前来讲听有啊，
就我们的播客圈子里面还是非常好的，
那你要是跟那个视频圈子里面。
对我的伤害比起来，
那这个我觉得，
这个就怎么讲呢，
这个算是，
这个算是微微辣，
就是按照辣椒的成分来讲，
这就叫微微辣，
几乎等同于不辣，
但但我也不是说让大家暴风雨来的。
再猛烈一点啊，
就保持这种状态，
我觉得挺好的，
你轻松一点听播客，
我轻松一点做播客，
我们相安无事，
安安稳稳的，
我们再过下一个50年，
嘿嘿,
下一个50年，
挺好的，
好吧,
那么今天这一期节目就聊那么多，
关于特斯拉帽多湾，
现在是全球，
逍量第一的车型，
那么大家有什么想聊的，
想说的，
评论区都可以交流，
如果想关注我更多的原创内容的话，
我的长视频在bilibili，
搜索跟我的播客同名叫摆车全说，
那么我的短视频在抖音，
视频号小红书和快手，
叫三刀砍车，
单人盘的单人旁砍大山的砍，
那么还有就是我的新档微博摆车全说三刀，
那么隔壁也有我一档双人对谈类的节目，
就是请我的好朋友来做客，
叫做小式牛刀，
事呢就是事情的事，
你如果节目不够听，
你可以去隔壁的专辑再去搜索一下，
好吧,
那么没有订阅的，
听到这儿了，
我觉得可以喜马拉雅小宇之后都帮我订阅一下，
那么如果喜马拉雅的听用呢，
在那个播放页面，
就是小三角的下方，
可以投一投免费的月票，
好的,
那么想联系我，
可以加微信46415254，
今天这期节目就到这里，
我们下一期接着聊，
拜拜。